uh compared to the top computer
suggestions but that's still very good
that's very accurate and Eric meanwhile
still good 43 uh but not in the same uh
accuracy level as Magnus uh okay the
game has started it's an Italian opening
but we will talk about some of these
stats as we go along especially end
games
87. how incredible is that number I mean
that's just meaning he wins 80 of the
games that goes into the end game that's
crazy or at least it's accuracy uh yeah
I mean that's I mean he's
clearly one of the best endgame players
of all time he's got a endgames is a
really interesting era of of Chess which
I'm definitely uh not uh feeling most
comfortable in but
um a lot of it's just to do with peace
placement intuition good calculation and
Magnus Scott all of those of course
temporary to keep the queen size
never enter the end game with Magnus it
looks that way I think that's just good
advice for anyone in general it's funny
I went out into the foyer and I saw it
it was being played on the big screen
um but what a curious opening by Magnus
to go for this this is what I used to
play when I was 12 years old uh oh
that's it's not the most popular opening
necessarily like you say after kind of
Club level yeah especially at Grand
Master Level you very rarely see this
nowadays but impressive stats that's the
thing if you know an opening really well
even if objectively it's maybe not the
best opening then you'll get good
results if you know it better than your
opponent and this one
yeah it's out of fashion and maybe
that's just a good
uh kind of a good piece of advice to
follow if an opening is out of fashion
you can reinvent it you can pick it up
your opponent might not be familiar with
what to do
um so the memory wasn't that nice
because it was like oh I'm beating I'm
beating mamajarov or I'm better oh yeah
and here he was deciding whether to push
F3 and kick the Knight immediately or
Play Bishop B3 and there are some small
nuances for example in this position
here
if I remember them correctly the move
Queen E7 now exists and now if you kick
the Knight with F3 you've got this
surprising move Knight to D6 because the
uh because the bishop on E3 is hanging
however Eric goes the the standard way
with Bishop B6 and now I expect Magnus
to kick with F3 he'll move the Knight to
G5 and then he'll probably kick the
Knight again with F4
gaining some time it's a bit worrying to
see that Eric is pausing at this moment
it's something that for sure he studied
at some point maybe when he was 12 years
old as you mentioned that Lawrence but
if the world Champion's playing this
against you and it's so direct it's so
unbalanced you really need to know what
you're doing okay it's a rare line or an
older line that we mentioned but okay
pushing a pawn forward now and then he's
gonna get on with his plan of pushing
forward the F1 there it comes I was
beginning to question my life it's
existence and if that pawn wasn't going
to get pushed but this would just invite
white Ford so yeah the Knight does
indeed recentralize and now Magnus tries
to trade off Black's best piece it's
heating up this game I think from its
opening it's much more promising than
the last last game we followed yeah
definitely feels uh entertaining and
balanced everything we could hope for
and it's a very unifying event you know
you have dinner with your team you
analyze with your team you have
breakfast you play the games alongside
yeah we have a couple more white tonight
has been kicked away from the center so
as Ivanka was advocating both sides
pushing pawns blacks C Pawn pushing the
White Knight I don't really like the
squares landed on but maybe it was
necessary and Eric's dilemma is what to
do with his own night does he trade off
you try and maintain it there it's not
that easy to do so
Magnus meanwhile laughing to himself or
he was at least a moment ago something
we've seen But back to the poker face if
we could get that position every game
and and now we're gonna see it so let's
see what Eric does here and he's going
to take a pause rapid game where you
don't have time to calculate it looks so
scary whoops sorry to allow this upon
stepping forward and he actually plays
your move
um your first instinct so The Bishop's
potentially on a good diagonal if things
open up but this one is blocked in and
your king is kind of left to its own
devices look at that here we go there we
go and we have it on the board you know
I mean it's every person's dream right I
mean I don't care what the computer says
computers could say like black is
winning but I'd be very happy yeah it's
people I mean just look at that King
it's got zero Defenders around it it's
got two pawns rushing towards it the
bishop is coming to this Square maybe
even to sacrifice itself to open things
up The Rook could potentially be coming
at some point to swing over
I don't really see any sacrifices
working okay he does play it
um maybe he needed to oh now things get
very exciting because
all kinds of things are in the air here
now if white takes this Pawn or white
leaves it Bishop G5 here just moving
away you gain an important temper
because you can play Queen to D5
and you're threatening mate all of a
sudden so I do like this move and Magnus
has decided to take yeah and now
actually taking back is not automatic
whatsoever that's the real threat just
activating those Rooks yeah okay he's
going for it I think we will see this
position on the board and
um if Eric puts his Queen in Center he
has just done as you mentioned there as
He suggests Lawrence but uh now is the
time for white to regroup and start
looking after The King and I like
magnus's last move I was also maybe
considering moving The Rook up one
square as well just to kind of over
protect the queen oh you can and it has
been taken it has been taken okay the
idea is that the bishop Falls but if the
bishop falls to the black queen can take
the white Bishop which was hanging and
we'd be in an end game Magnus loves
those end games that we've seen but the
question is in this position is White's
King good in the corner no the black
Bishop's pretty decent white tonight
also very good but uh is it enough to
win
not easy not easy and if Magnus doesn't
go for this if he doesn't go for the end
game what's he doing uh he risks being
worse if he leaves the two black bishops
on the board he does take it and we're
gonna head straight into the same game
okay
well now we can take a breath and uh
Eric won't lose on time he's uh still
got some work to do though it's
especially this white knight which
controls two squares the black Rooks
want to use black wants to use this
Square black maybe wants to use this
square but both are covered by this
Knight so this Knight is a real thorn in
his side let's put it like that and
gives us the part we always want to
study always it's the part we pretend we
study but it's actually hard to knuckle
down and say okay I'm gonna look at Rook
end games today yeah Grandma's are out
of Hamburg an in-game freak in in a good
sense right and you know he just does
end games end games end games
um
it's it's it's tough It's it's almost a
different game somehow but uh Magnus
playing I've been looking at this and
I've been trying to work out what kind
of setup I would play and he puts the
bishop on C5 and he wants to put the
bishop on D6 and just use that Bishop as
a bit of a uh what I oh if you could
imagine a wine bottle cork
so when you've had a glass of wine you
put the cork back in that's what that
Bishop would do on D6 it was ah it would
it doesn't matter if I can work with you
can put well you can put the one system
you can put those rubber cords back in
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um that's that's how I view but actually
Eric isn't quite in time to
to get the configuration he wants now
the cork if you put it back in the
bottle then you drop this point or does
he or can you well maybe maybe you can
do it anyway with pawns on both sides of
the board it's doing an okay job he's
doing fine yeah potentially potentially
there are still some interesting issues
there but okay he goes he does go for it
yeah cook is back in the bottle
party tonight I think you've got to
because if you allow black now just to
play A4 on the next move Rook fe8 King
to f8 and consolidate
zero-ish in fact you start to prefer
black because there's a bit of pressure
so he's he's going active Ivanka yeah he
had to do I think he had to do this and
well Magnus is uh pushing his bones on
the queen side and uh at least the Rooks
got active it has got active but uh
the White Knight just comes back and is
also acting like the cork you mentioned
just uh keeping all those pawns
protected uh and if Bishop F6 B3 and
rugby two also exists of course yeah
okay you can bully your opponent now
you're a pawn up uh Rook drops back
actually yeah it feels like Magnus is
consolidating he's regrouped holding
everything together because you
associate when the court comes out the
bottle you associate with good times
right imagine you've got a miserable
position it's like congratulations
congratulations
yes now this is miserable now for Eric
and uh well he's doing some active
thinking of pushing the age Pawn
that's that's a plan but the problem is
is that his Works although active they
don't actually have any purpose I mean
black Rook on the A-line has to guard
against the advance of the white apron
so
um and uh well Magnus is coming forward
yeah it's so instructive what Magnus has
done as well with the white king the
white King was on the first rank it was
a terrible piece but now it's on a
really nice Square on a light Square
Magnus is going for that light Square
strategy right just putting everything
on the opposite color from the
opponent's Bishop
uh I was also on the lights going out
stopping the Black Brook from attacking
those horns on the third rank yeah it's
just slow and steady
um what is Eric's plan look at Eric's
body language as well just kind of
exhaling we've all been there right when
we know we're struggling we just don't
have a plan and
it's kind of a double whammy when your
opponent is the greatest end game player
of all time
it's like uh the tortoise and the hair
right this is tortoise just slow and
steady wins the race I must remember it
like a snail just one square forward and
move later another square and uh The
Rook moves to the edge of the board and
well this is very exciting position we
see Magnus doing magnus's things and uh
whilst Eric is thinking sorry Magnus is
thinking just like to share with you a
few selfies uh first one comes from
jmr18 who says that they're watching us
from the Beer Garden in rainy Germany oh
well still very cool yeah Garden so
cheers to you I'm gonna salute you with
my tea
and the night Retreats again over
protecting all the pawns I love this
type of chess I mean this is the worst
possible thing you could ever wish for
against Magnus this is just you've got
no counter play your dynamism doesn't
exist you are just slowly getting
strangled
and Eric knows this yeah Eric is fully
aware of what's going on it's
yeah you sounded like that Eeyore just
then
from Winnie the Pooh Winnie the Pooh oh
no oh
um yeah
um sorry no no no it's I take it he was
he was cuddly and nice wasn't he or I'll
take it yeah
um no this is horrible yeah Knight G4 is
a great move the evaluation bar showed
up I was wondering whether white could
have been greedy or just gone to grab a
second porn White's Rook on the C file
I could have grabbed that isolated Pawn
on C7 and Magnus yeah just keeping
control and you could just see at that
sigh from Eric
he just knows it's over Magnus is in his
elements
yeah for any chess player this is uh
suffering but
actually when this is your opponent and
okay the bishop moving
makes some sense but now he gets greedy
and I think he's got enough control
Magnus that he can get away with this
and he checks on the second rank will be
blocked by White's F Rook
um The Rook is sitting there near the
white king which we'll see most likely
think the king wants to go on any
Journeys into the corner just feels
unnecessary so block the check yeah
it's lined it up so beautifully I mean
there's no tactics whatsoever
Eric's favor and
he moves his Rook tactics against the
black king
do you see what's happening yeah we're
gonna see actually Magnus go on the
attack uh the black king when it moves
to this okay is Eric gonna resign
because if you block this check it's
pretty much the same as resigning right
um you can drop back with the black Rook
or the black Bishop but if the King goes
to the edge of the board the White
Knight is going to jump into the center
and start going for the black king
okay we'll see this on the board
it's the white knight will jump to the
middle attack the rook and also threaten
the F7 Pawn and the black king is in a
mating net yeah I think we're going to
see just body language wise Eric is
about to resign any moment
and there we go the black Christmas
attack the black porn was attacked
nothing to be done yeah it's a win for
Magnus Carlsen striking back after
losing in the first round now three
points in this uh second game against
Eric Hanson it was a great game by the
world number one 41 moves he took it
into the end game